I want you to imagine a very dangerous
day you wake up in the morning looking
like this after a very very peaceful
night however the house you've just
woken up in is in an area that's
surrounded by pace which is very prone
to earthquakes tornadoes and hurricanes
you get out of bed you go down to your
bathroom you fill up your bathroom sink
full of water and you push aside all of
the electrical appliances next to you
you don't get electrocuted on your way
out of the bathroom on the way out of
the house you grab the only thing which
you can find for breakfast which happens
to be a very high in fat high calorie
high sugar high cholesterol breakfast as
the only thing you have on the way out
of the house you narrowly avoid your
swimming pool you don't fall into your
swimming pool and you do not drown and
as you get to your car you narrowly
avoid eye contact with your neighbor
whom you know really hates you and has
an assault rifle in this backyard you
get into York I started driving in turn
on the radio you hear stories of Isis
Ebola measles all of these risks some of
the most contagious and deadly diseases
to ever reach American soil you get to
your destination which happens to be an
airport you get into a giant tube of
metal you go up 35,000 feet in the air
supported only by wings which are narrow
narrow and thinner than your car door
you're fine and just before you go to
sleep you reach into the seat pocket in
front of you you grab the bag of peanuts
you read the choking hazard you're fine
you eat the peanuts if you go to sleep
everything's okay pretty dangerous day
did you know that out of all of these
risks that you had today the the peanuts
are angry neighbor with the assault
rifle the high calorie breakfast the
swing for tebow none of these were the
most dangerous things he did today it
was actually getting into your car and
driving every year 1.2 million people
died on our roads to put that into
perspective that's the equivalent of a
jumbo jet
full of people falling out of the sky
every three hours every three hours
every single day every single week every
single month every single year now I
came to Stanford to think what can I do
what is my role in preventing the
massive spectrum of human suffering and
what can i do to substantially improve
human life and when I look at these
statistics I think this is a pretty good
place to start why does this happen what
can we do about it well it turns out the
93% of accidents happen because of human
error why because we're human we get
careless we make mistakes we get
distracted we're rational we make bad
decisions we're human the problem is
with accidents that when we get into one
we don't just affect ourselves but we
affect other people around us as well
therefore if you want to do something to
substantially reduce a number of people
who died on our roads we need to do
something about taking out some of the
human elements from driving and
replacing it by computers that can make
better faster more accurate decisions on
our behalf and it looks like this an
autonomous vehicle now as soon as I say
replacing some of the human elements of
driving with cold hard computer I'm
already feeling this visceral reaction
that we have in this room about
extracting some of the warm fuzzy
emotional human elements and replacing
it with cold hard numbers but I want you
to go with me for one moment go me for a
second I want you to imagine a safer
world I want you to imagine a safer
world where 35,000 people do not die on
our roads every single year that's two
people since this talk began I want you
to imagine a safer world where you do
not have to share your roads with
sixty-five percent of other drivers who
are using their cell phones at the same
time
time I want you to imagine a safer world
with a 112 million people who drive
under the influence of alcohol are not
driving on the same roads of my future
children and your children are going to
be playing on and lastly I want you to
imagine a safer world where you never
have to look for parking again nor pay
another parking fine imagine that world
why aren't we there yet tamiya comes
down to how we make decisions about
adopting new technologies both as
consumers and also as regulators you see
good decision-making about whether to
adopt a new technology or not is made by
understanding diligently the benefits
and the costs if the benefits outweigh
the costs and you do adopt the new
technology otherwise you do not the
problem is that with autonomous vehicles
we have no idea what the benefits are
because we haven't tried them we haven't
given them a shot on the other hand as
soon as we start thinking of the risks
given that we live in such a risk-averse
society we blow these risks out of
proportion and we engage our
rationalities and fears to make them
much larger than what they are and
that's something to think about because
when we want to understand which
technologies to adopt we need to
understand both of them now additionally
to being at the GSB I'm also magician am
I my job as a magician is to understand
where the line is drawn between
perception and reality and when I think
of the risks of autonomous vehicles I
don't see reality i see perceived risks
i'll explain you see a lot of people
think it's terrible to give up their
control of their driving to someone else
but they have no issue about getting
into an uber and giving up their control
of the driving to someone they have no
idea about they have no issue and we
have no issue about getting to an
airplane and letting our flights be
controlled by computers on autopilot we
have no
shoo getting into a new york subway or
london underground and having the the
flow of the carriages controlled by car
cold hard numerical algorithms at
computers already make life-or-death
decisions for us on a daily basis and
it's time to apply that to the number
one cause of death for people between
the ages of 3 and 34 so what I ask of
you is not to put aside your fears of
autonomous vehicles but to keep them
into proportion and also give necessary
credence to their benefits as well the
fact that we don't have to live in the
world where 35,000 people die on just us
roads every year the fact you will not
have to share your your roads are people
who are either drunk or texting the fact
that you will have it countless extra
hours every year two of extra economic
productivity what I ask of you is not to
justice count autonomous vehicles as a
new in thing the new fad of Silicon
Valley but to go out and to tell your
friends to tell your colleagues to tell
your family about how much safer this
world would be if we begin to adopt them
one day I want to look back into the
world that we live in today where there
was so much unnecessary human suffering
and think that we and autonomous
vehicles were part of that solution
thank you